yeah no pressure so I saw on Twitter
today that 46 years ago today Johnny
Cash sat down with Richard Nixon to talk
about prison reform and of course this
year Kim Kardashian did the same thing
with President Trump but many
celebrities like Johnny Cash sort of
have this you know an American dream
like they started off with a hard life
and they succeeded because their talent
so do you think that celebrities like
that have anything positive to
contribute toward this course well it's
a complicated issue I just wrote a book
about it yes and I think many Mark Twain
for example in some ways was the first
media celebrity in this country was a
great example of the American Dream he
came out of nowhere and became a
world-renowned author and became very
wealthy they've lost it all then became
wealthy again and so but this creates a
problem for celebrities look at for me
cysts
the great Austrian economist wrote about
this in his book the anti capitalist
mentality because he was already
speculating why are so many entertainers
anti-capitalist and he said much of what
they achieve is because of luck and they
feel guilty about it
and I think a lot of what you see coming
out specifically in Hollywood are the
secret guild feelings of people of the
cornered great Fame great wealth knowing
that it often turns on just one little
moment in their careers or the genetic
fact that they're so good-looking
and so this disposition to be often
socialist and certainly anti-capitalist
I think can be traced to the fact that
they are aware that
that their success isn't based on
anything very solid and of course it's
also fleeting and they live in fear of
that so it is a curious fact that so
many of the beneficiaries of the
American Dream and again I'd say a lot
of people on Hollywood stand for that
are themselves very dubious about it and
will recognize the fact that they've
they've lived it out themselves are you
saying that Johnny Cash is better than
Kim Kardashian dress better and so I
think when you look at celebrity and how
they are trying to use their platform
you can see through whether or not
people are doing it just to gain
attention or whether there could be good
intentions behind it and I think that's
what she played off well she met with
someone who she knew she was gonna get
criticized for meeting with and then
told the story of a woman she was trying
to help and I think that's why it would
say worked worked well at her favor in
that situation some months ago I was at
an airport lounge and I picked up the
New York Times it's the only type lever
look at the New York Times and print and
I opened it to the op-ed page to see
what they were doing on there out that
page and the lead op-ed was a piece on
the Rohingya crisis the refugees from
Burma I guess were supposed to call it
Myanmar now and the byline if I recall
correctly was by Angelina Jolie and John
McCain
and I just kind of rolled my eyes I
thought all right first of all Angelina
Jolie did not write this maybe John
McCain did but probably had a staffer
work on it I mean why do I want to read
this piece by Angelina Jolie and
ostensibly by Angelina Jolie and John
McCain I mean it's just a silly gimmick
so I have a general look you read it no
I've read the byline I saw what it was
not no I didn't read it I probably read
former Enron advisor Paul Krugman
instead all right so I have a general
aversion to these kinds of pieces and
you won't see a lot of celebrity written
op eds on all right on our page while
I'm editing it I did run one which was
by the singer Moby all right which I
like because it was about food stamps
and he was arguing I think he was
arguing that food stamps shouldn't be
shouldn't be allowed to use food stamps
to buy junk food but he was recounting
his personal experience I growing up
living with a single mother and being
dependent on food stamps so there was
there was a certain authenticity there
that I liked and so I was happy to have
have Moby in the page but I mean the
idea that we should pay attention to
some celebrities cause just because the
person is famous is one that I find
somewhat vexing okay but like a true
political philosopher like Merle Haggard
yeah James you said that The Daily News
may be on its last legs but you didn't
give us a prophecy about the newspaper
industry in general I mean is there a
way for newspapers really to maintain
their air socratic status or is the New
York Times eventually going to be
reduced to begging thawne's like NPR
well the New York Times I looked this up
because I thought it might be relevant
to why to my talk here all right New
York Times stock has risen by about 150
percent since election day so what that
suggests I mean I haven't you know
looked at all the factors that might
influence that although I will say News
Corp stock has risen considerably less I
think it's about 50% that's the company
that owns the journal in the New York
close to one others I but it does appear
that the
from I insanity has been good for the
New York Times commercially at least in
the short run now to the extent that the
New York Times depended on its has
depended on its reputation as the paper
of record as you know even though it's
understood to be liberal as at least
attempting objectivity I I think that it
will harm them in the long run as an
institution but there's probably a
commercial market for at least a few
newspapers all right but the the the
business in general I think is is in
trouble and I don't I mean maybe
somebody will find a new business model
I don't know exactly what it will be but
the journal is doing fine I think the
journal will be alright at least until I
retire all right yes sir my name is kami
but I'm with the Pakistani Spectator and
my question is what should be the real
concern of should be concerned that
Democrat gets some inspiration from
Hollywood or what Hollywood teach should
be the serious concern like you know
your little son could have to dad or
your little daughter could have two
mommies and if that is the real concern
then you know Department of State is
full with 50% lesbian and gays and
that's what they reflect America outside
so as a being a Muslim American or
Pakistani American in the city for 35
years
I feel more concerned about those issues
that these people are somehow destroying
America from inside question about the
culture so what you see in Hollywood and
what you see in movies putting out there
you can go back to probably the first TV
show as far as showing gay couples
Will and Grace and if you took and I
don't know what the number is if you
took the percentage of people in the
country at that point and what they
thought about gay marriage would be very
different than what it is today so right
or wrong whether you agree it that or
you don't I do think that what people
see in movies and what people see in TV
definitely changes people's opinions of
the issue as more time goes on and it
goes back to the power of seeing people
and telling stories and that's something
that the left on many issues has been
great at which is let's let's get you to
think about an issue in a certain way
because we're going to show you the
people behind it and so I even see when
it comes to traditional news media that
they are following that same form I
think the most recent immigration issue
at the border is a prime example where
the main narrative was about visuals of
children and talking to the families
they're not a thorough discussion on the
nuanced aspect of the policy that was
behind all this and just the history of
immigration in general so where I will
fault the left on many issues not that
they tell stories I think it's very
effective but that we don't have
thoughtful thorough discussion and
social media is not helping with
thorough discussion about anything and
when news media and even many newspapers
are going to make a sensationalized
narrative only showing one side of the
issue that's where we get ourselves into
a lot of trouble I will say on that one
I am encouraged by when it comes to
technology and telling narratives is the
explosion of podcasts so in here listens
to podcasts I'm sure a lot of people do
love podcasts I think in some ways the
podcast culture is a reflection of us
being frustrated by the short characters
that we get think of sound bites and
news packages that we saw on TV or even
just Twitter oh it's not many words to
talk about in issues
very excited about podcast and that even
Millennials are driven to them probably
because you can binge listen to them
which makes it a lot easier and they're
very few commercials which is helpful
but also because I do think that we
crave long-form discussion in a way
that's conversational nails in the back
right there yeah hi um I was reading the
New York Times a couple weeks ago and
there's a headline here that I read a
jury may have sentence a man to death
because he's gay and the justices don't
care and I went on to read that it's an
opinion piece I read the rest of the
piece and it turned out what happened
was there was a gay man who committed a
murder and was sentenced to death and
the author of the article argued that
the jury was biased against the man
because he was gay and therefore
sentenced him to death so obviously
there's sort of a misleading title there
that if you were scanning through the
headlines and you read that you might
assume oh there are homophobic judges
just sentencing people to death for
homosexuality so could you speak a
little bit on the idea of clickbait
headlines in a especially in the context
of a publication like the New York Times
that one would think would be a
respectable institution
well I wouldn't necessarily think you've
written an article and somebody else
picks it up and changes your a title
which happens a lot
there are recourses that people can take
to ensure that that or try to make it so
it doesn't happen again sadly it's the
nature of clicks mean more than sound
journalism and the only recourse in my
opinion to that is people getting fed up
with it so I do think as we silo
ourselves into okay I agree with this
perspective so I'm just gonna go to this
news outlet I think if more and more
people who want straight journalism and
just want the facts that's when things
change but if there's an audience for
the clickbait it's gonna continue it
isn't market driven who read the article
yeah and that's what they wanted to
happen and as all these print base media
also have online press
they need those clicks but isn't this
also driving a desire to get things up
very very fast
yes and is this what's killing the the
used to be a need for two sources what
killed that well I mean I think the two
source rule is not necessarily an
especially good rule
you might just be getting one source
about you might just need any one guy
who hears it from somebody else and then
sourcing is a whole lie a whole other
story - you have a story that's solidly
source but the sources have bias and the
journalists don't tell you what the
sources are or how the sources are
biased all right my favorite is so the
New York Times in particular does this
they decided they want to try to explain
why people are asking for anonymity so
you get these hilarious explanations you
know blah blah blah said a person who
spoke on in it our request of anonymity
I to avoid i offending you know the
president or whatever well the
president's gonna be offended you know
it's often you look at this and you
realize don't notice the the the real
reason is obviously self-interested but
it's framed as a sort of high-minded way
right here hi so my question is given
the way politics today it's very tribal
like and you know my question is given
that also with social media a lot of
fake news and you know a lot of
Americans kind of just given their
preconceived notions of no politics how
do we grass an articulate public policy
that's gonna be based on you know
actually providing people with you know
real facts and think of them through
these things that and understand you
know how liberal democracy works and how
we can actually engage in actual debate
that's based on you know actual
compromise the president in that he
tweets so much but it takes all the air
space and all the media loves to cover
it so we don't have thoughtful
discussion even like we used to before
he as president even though I'd say it
was too limited because these days
that's more entertaining he is
entertaining
I even think he does himself a huge
disservice cuz he'll cover good stories
going on and then tweet something
personally about someone and then that
becomes a story even though a great
study came out about how tax reform is
helping people for example as far as how
do we deal with the tribalistic aspect I
do think that Trump is a response to
Obama and people felt disillusioned by
by Obama and so Trump was the
alternative to that unfortunately he's
just continuing to dig in on tribalism I
think it comes from our leaders higher
up I think you can be a tough talker
without being as divisive as the
president can be with rhetoric so take
his his policies aside or good things
that have happened in my opinion under
his administration it's the way we talk
to each other and with each other and
when you have rhetoric that is very
divided and you just see both sides
doing it now you don't get anywhere and
people just entrench themselves even
further into their own perspective so I
think it starts with quality rhetoric
and good rhetoric and more airspace to
be able to do that in the media yeah I
agree with that that is wrong to place
all the blame for this on the American
people and the new media let's face it
our politicians are abandoning their
obligation to serve the public good and
I put most of the blame on Congress it
is supposed to be a deliberative body
I'm old enough to remember in the 1960s
when Senators would get up and give
thoughtful speeches and maybe even sway
people with a good argument I did you
know you could go back through American
history and read famous speeches by
famous senators and what we're gonna
have a library of America's just going
to do the collected tweets of Congress
someday now what is there left they so I
to me the biggest failure is in our
legislature in its refusal to be a
legislature and to talk seriously about
about these issues of what good policy
is I don't know I'm gonna say a word on
defensive in defense of Twitter here all
right I mean my tweets Senate Senators
gave thoughtful speeches in the 60s I'm
sure some of them were very good they
were very nice in PO's aook twitter is a
sort of poetry and I think there's
something to be said for that sort of
form I mean I love president Trump's
tweets nation
I meant poetry and Twitter is not so it
took a Donald Trump using Twitter to
break through what seemed to be a
monolithic liberal journalism and now
there's reacting they don't know what to
do about it but that's what broke
through isn't that well and also the
Republican establishment I mean Trump
not only took to have the Clinton
dynasty took down the bush dynasty first
it was astonishing that's that's useful
now troublesome brilliant and finding a
way around traditional media and I give
him a ton of credit for that he's a
master of earned media the key is
something to watch his Twitter feed is
entertaining it's like what is he gonna
tweet this morning it's highly
entertaining its captivating but I think
there's backlash to it it these steps on
his own toes but he got around what
we're due for was an established elite
as we're talking about it and I think
what he's been able to do even more so
as so as the left is more enraged by
what he says and would have does on
Twitter their antics increase which then
allows him to attack them even more so
that low low IQ Maxine is what he calls
her it and like if you thought careful
what you wish for max
match or exceed some of what he was
already saying so it's it's almost as if
they plan to his hand because they're so
outraged by what he's doing so all they
have to do is stop and yeah doesn't work
that's all right simplest simple plan
you've been waiting so he'll come up
here like question okay make it good
make it good English professor here make
it good arguably one of the functions of
aristocracy is the provision of
narratives that legitimizes the
prevailing social order if Hollywood is
the new aristocracy does it provide well
doesn't manufacture or facilitate
America's Civic mythology and does it do
it well you know I would describe how it
was a false aristocracy and indeed that
was Twain's point about what he saw as a
heresy in America because you know I
don't want to go defend aristocracy but
the whole idea behind the aristocracy
was inherited wealth inherited position
so that people could take the long term
view of things and that's exactly the
opposite of our Hollywood aristocracy
which is after all awfully ephemeral
these stars come out of nowhere and then
they disappear there was an old joke
about about how he described the career
of a Hollywood star and they used Hugh
O'Brien whom none of you have heard of
the young but older people know he was
Wyatt Earp and the idea was you had the
cycle of a Hollywood career it who is
you O'Brien can't be you O'Brien get me
a young you O'Brien who was your Briah
that ll stars go through that cycle so
that we called an aristocracy it's a
kind of metaphor it really isn't an
aristocracy and in some ways the last
people in the world to take a long
term broad-based view of the public good
are people in Hollywood so I don't know
where we could get a real aristocracy
from or even a reasonable facsimile of
one when you do have Hollywood
commenting on social media that the
facade kind of goes away so I think as
they talk more insert themselves into
politics into whatever else the magic of
not knowing what's behind like the the
silver screen so to speak goes away so I
don't think as they comment more it
helps them build up themselves as who
you look to I actually think it does the
opposite it also seems to me all right
they don't have the kind of you don't
have people with the sort of universal
presence Universal influence they used
to have I think of Rob Reiner for
example who's you know this nutty like
70 year old approximately our actor all
right who posts these crazy tweets about
about Trump a lot of people in the
audience probably don't remember that 45
years ago Rob Reiner was one of the
stars of a show called all in the family
that was I had you know tens of millions
of people watched every week and it was
it was a big deal you know you you say
Archie Bunker to a millennial of these
days and they had a blank star stare but
it was the use of major eye
cultural eye icon of the 1970s and into
the 80s and what do we have that's the
equivalent of that today not not much I
think no I think that's right I guess so
we can be thankful at very least this
technology which is giving us this elite
is also destroying it it's not there's
so many different options you don't have
to it's not just movie stars it's the TV
like we're saying it's it's a collective
of it all means that they're fewer and
fewer people who just stand out and it's
given technology in America anybody can
be of the aristocracy thank you all
thank you very much and thank you all
for joining us
[Applause]